TERRIFIC IDEAS THAT WERE, IN
REAL EXPERIENCES.
AND THAT IS THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW IS KELLY CONLEY,
FOR IMMERSING THE CONSUL TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP, ENTER AT-LARGE
LARGE AND A SPECTATOR IN
CHARLIE HURT, ALL THREE ARE
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR'S.
KELLY AND THE START WITH YOU,
WHAT IS NARRATIVE COME FROM?
THAT THE DEMOCRATS, THEY HAVE
ALL THE MOMENTUM.
HEAD AND INTO 2024.
GIVEN WHAT I JUST LAID OUT?
>> HE CAME FROM DEMOCRATS,
COMES FROM THE DIFFICULT
INCLUDING THEIR NEIGHBORS IN THE
MEDIA LOOK AT SUPER SILLY TO
SPEAK AND IT'S WISHFUL THINKING
THEY ARE STUCK WITH THIS GUY IN
LARGE PART BECAUSE KEEPING HIM
IN, HANDS OFF THE 2022 CAMPAIGN
TRAIL HELP THE DEMOCRATS GAIN A
SEAT IN THE SENATE, AND NEARLY
LOSE THE HOUSE.
SO, AND 2024.
BRANDON HARRIS CANNOT ESCAPE
CAMPAIGNING FOR BIDEN AND
HARRIS.
CURRY CALIFORNIA KIM AND
MARILYN, HIM AND UNION STATION
AND UNION STATION LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IS NOT A SWING STATE,
IT IS NOT A SWING CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICT IS A TRAIN DEPOT.
AND THAT'S WHERE THEY PUT THE
PRESENT THE PRESENT
UNITED STATES TO CAMPAIGN 1024
IS DIFFERENT BUT BUDDIES GOT
PROBLEMS OTHER THAN THE 66% OF
INDEPENDENTS AND WANTED TO RUN.
IN THE 66% OF SENIORS THAT SAY
HIS TO RUN.
I THINK THE BIGGER PROBLEMS AND
IS PULLING HIS DISAPPROVAL
RIBBON IS DOWN AGAIN, AND HIS
APPROVAL AND ECONOMIES DONE
AGAIN, AND ONLY 20% OF AMERICANS
ACCORDING TO THE CNBC PEOPLE
BELIEVE THAT JOE BIDEN'S
POLICIES ON INFLATION ACTUALLY
HELPING WITH INFLATION.
IN AUGUST OR SO, THEY PASS THIS
INFLATION REDUCTION, AND YOU
FIND ME TIME DEMOCRATS IN THE
SENATE WHO VOTED FOR THAT
INFLATION PROTECTION ACT, WHO
ACTIVELY RAN ON VOTING FOR THE
INNOVATION REDUCTION ACT.
IN CHUCK CAN RANGE IS REAL,
THERE IS NO VACCINE OR BOOSTER,
TO REAL DISEASE -- AND GUESS
WHAT, INTENTIONALLY FOR THEIR
ELECTION IS VERY SIMPLE.
AS A REFERENDUM ABOUT JOE BIDEN.
IN ANY SENATE OPPONENT ALL THESE
BAD POLICIES.
>> SENATOR SCHUMER THINKS THAT
HE CAN PASS THIS NEXT SPENDING
BILL -- WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
WATCH.
>> A YEAR LONG ON THAT THIS IS
THE BEST AND MOST BALLAST OPTION
TO FUND OUR GOVERNMENT.
IN AN OMNIBUS IS THE MOST
BALANCED APPROACH BECAUSE IT
WILL CONTAIN PRIORITIES BOTH
SIDES WANT TO SEE.
FUNDING FOR UKRAINE.
LET US NOT WORK TOGETHER AGAIN
TO IMPLEMENT THEM FULLY.
>> CHARLIE MITCH McCONNELL
IS GIVING CHUCK SCHUMER JUST
WHAT HE WANTS.
GOING INTO THE NEXT YEAR.
REPUBLICANS WILL HAVE NO
LEVERAGE OF THE HOUSE TO CHANGE
PRETTY MUCH ANYTHING UP UNTIL
OCTOBER.
BUT ONCE AGAIN, THE UNIT PARTY
STRIKES.
>> YES, AND IT'S ABSOLUTELY
APPALLING ESPECIALLY IN A MOMENT
LIKE RIGHT NOW WHERE REPUBLICANS
SHOULD HAVE THE UPPER HAND
ESPECIALLY IN A FIGHT LIKE THIS.
TO DEMONSTRATE HOW THEY INTEND
TO GOVERN DIFFERENTLY.
EVEN IF THAT MEANS NOT GIVING,
THE GOVERNMENT ARE NOT GIVING
DEMOCRATS WHAT IT IS THAT THEY
ARE SEEKING TO DO.
AND I THINK, CARRIE IS EXACTLY
RIGHT.
VOTERS UNDERSTAND THIS THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT THE REASON THAT
THEY'RE PAYING SO MUCH MORE AT
THE GROCERY STORE RIGHT NOW IS
BECAUSE A DEMOCRAT POLICIES THAT
IS CAUSING INFLATION.
ONE THING I DO HAVE TO SAY
THOUGH, ABOUT THAT I ADMIRE AND
WHAT DEMOCRATS ARE DOING IS
THEIR ABILITY -- AND THEIR
DESIRE TO NOT TALK ABOUT IDEAS
BECAUSE THEY'RE WRONG ON ALL THE
IDEAS, BUT THE DESIRES TO PIN
EVERY CANDIDATE TO DONALD TRUMP.
AND REPUBLICANS MADE A BIGGER
STAKE IN THIS LAST ELECTION,
THEY FAILED TO PIN EVERY SINGLE
CANDIDATE OUT THERE RUNNING TO
JOE BIDEN.
BECAUSE THAT, IN REALITY IS WHAT
ALL THOSE PEOPLE WERE DOING,
ALTHOUGH DEMOCRATS ARE RUNNING
TO BE A RUBBER STAMP FOR
JOE BIDEN.
JOE BIDEN'S POPULARITY IS LOW,
MISSING TO BE EVEN LOWER WHEN HE
HAS TO GO OUT THERE AND DEFEND
HIMSELF.
AND, I THINK THAT REPUBLICANS --
I THINK REPUBLICANS AND THEN I A
HARD GOING TO BE SUITED TO HAVE
A TREMENDOUS VICTORY IN 2024.
BUT, THEY COULD HAVE HAD A
BIGGER VICTORY THIS TIME IF IT
THEY HAD SUCCEEDED ATTENDING
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
DEMOCRATS TO JOE BIDEN AND HIS
HAPLESS POLICIES.
>> WHAT THEN OF COURSE THE
SENATORS VOTED TO PASS THIS, AND
AGAIN PEOPLE WATCHING THIS CAN'T
BELIEVE THIS IS HAPPENING BUT
THEY HAVE A THING CALLED A
STOPGAP SPENDING BILL, I HATE
ALL THIS, IT FRONTS THE
GOVERNMENT TILL NEXT THURSDAY OR
FRIDAY, AND THEN, OF COURSE THEY
CAN EXTEND THE FEDERAL CASH, BUT
THEN THE OMNIBUS WILL BE VOTED
ON AND THEN I PUSH THIS TO AT
SOME POINT BEFORE THE END OF THE
YEAR, IS THIS ANY WAY TO RUN A
GOVERNMENT?
IN ALL THIS REPUBLICANS AGREED
TO THIS BECAUSE THEY WANT
NEVER-ENDING FUNDING FOR UKRAINE
THAT THE SUPPOSEDLY WINNING THAT
WAR UNTIL THEY'RE NOT.
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK IT'S
JUST ABOUT HIM, AND ALSO THINK
IS AN INDICTMENT OF THE FACT
THAT WE'VE HAD THE SITUATION IN
WASHINGTON NOW FOR QUITE A LONG
TIME.
THIS IS NOW A NEW OCCURRENCE.
AND YET, WE CONTINUALLY JUST
ACCEPT THIS REALITY OF THESE
MASSIVE SPENDING BILLS, THAT
NOBODY ELSE HAS TIME TO READ
THAT THEY'RE ASKED TO VOTE ON
IMMEDIATELY.
THAT CONTAIN ALL SORTS OF
THINGS -- >> WHY?
>> BECAUSE WE HAVE A
DYSFUNCTIONAL LEADERSHIP, AND OF
FUNCTIONAL AND ANTI-CONSERVATIVE
LEADERSHIP WITHIN THE PUBLIC
IMPARTED THAT DOES NOT STAND IN
ANY FISCAL PRINCIPLE THEY ARE
NOT WILLING TO DO WHAT IT TAKES
OR TO TAKE ANY KIND OF SLINGS
AND ARROWS FROM A COMPLETELY
BIASED MEDIA THAT IS ENTIRELY
ENOUGH FOR THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
AND THEN IT WILL NOT STAND UP
FOR WHAT THEY ACTUALLY BELIEVE
IT IN AMERICA SHOULD BE SET UP
WITH THIS.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES FROM
THIS LEADERSHIP CLASS IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THAT SPENDING ON THINGS THAT
THEY WILL NOT BE AROUND TO PAY
THE BILLS FOR THE.
THAT THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE AROUND
TO EVEN SEE AND THAT YOUR
CHILDREN, AND YOUR CHILDREN'S
CHILDREN ARE GONNA BE PAYING FOR
WITH OUT AND INTO THE FUTURE.
AND A DIMINISHED FUTURE FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
FRANKLY, THIS IS GOING TO BE
OFFENSIVE TO ALL PEOPLE ON BOTH
SIDES BECAUSE IT IS NOT A WAY TO
RUN A GOVERNMENT IS NOT A WAY TO
FIND A COUNTRY.
>> AND 88 EUROS
SENATOR SHELBY, FROM ALABAMA IS
DELETE QUOTE NEGOTIATOR FOR THE
REPUBLICANS, ARE CARIGNAN CONWAY
MENTION GAVIN NEWSOM AS THE
OTHERS INVITED AN OPTION FOR THE
DEMOCRATS IN 2104.
THE POLITICAL REPORTED TODAY,
THE WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDS IT
TWEETED OUT THAT NEWSOM IS
PLANNING FOR JANUARY 6, BACK TO
JANUARY 6 INAUGURAL ADDRESS IN
SACRAMENTO.
TO BE A LARGE MARCH TO THE STATE
CAPITAL IN THE SPEECH FOCUSED ON
DEFENDING DEMOCRACY.
KELLY AND THERE ARE READING FROM
THE SAME HYMNAL HERE.
>> YOU KNOW THEY DO AND IT'S
SO SILLY BECAUSE WHAT IS HE
DOING ABOUT THE HOMELESS, THE
DRUG CRISIS, AND ABOUT HIS
BACKWOODS ECONOMIC STAY IN
CALIFORNIA, YOU KNOW WHAT LAURA
NEWS FLASH, THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY DOES NOT WANTED TO DO
CALIFORNIA IT'S A BEAUTIFUL
STATE AND WE STATE UMBRELLA
VISITING IT BUT WHAT IS HIS
ARGUMENT FOR IMPORT OR EXPORT
THAT TO THE REST OF THE COUNTRY?
BY THE WAY THE ONLY REASON THEY
TALK ABOUT GAVIN NEWSOM NOW, AS
AN HEIR TO JOE BIDEN'S NUMBER
ONE THE PEOPLE, THE 20 SOME
PEOPLE WHO RAN AGAINST JOE BIDEN
AT 20 TO AN AIR FREIGHT TO RUN
AGAINST HIM AGAIN.
WHERE.
WILL SANDERS MAYOR BUTTIGIEG?
WHY DOES INCUMBENT RUNNING
AGAINST HIM?
SHE DID LAST TIME BASICALLY
CALLING HIM A RACE IS ON THE
DEBATE SAY.
IN THE SECOND REASON TO TALK
ABOUT NEWSOM'S BECAUSE THERE
WILL HERO THE LEFT, THE LEFT OF
ANTI-PROMO, WAS DISGRACED OUT OF
OFFICE.
IN A SILLY REASON TO TALK LIKE
NEWSOM, BUT IT SHOWS YOU HOW TO
TURN THE BENCHES ARE, NOT
BENCHES FOLD WE HAVE SO MANY
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS REELECTED
THIS TIME, WITH OVERWHELMING
MARGINS.
IN FLORIDA, BUT ALSO IN
SOUTH CAROLINA, GEORGIA, AND
TEXAS, AND IOWA, AND TENNESSEE.
THEY ARE WAGES EXECUTIVE AND
THOSE ARE THE KIND OF POLICIES
THAT PEOPLE ARE LOOKING FOR.
LOOK, THE TENNESSEE TEAM THIS
CHUMP VERSUS BAD INSTALL IF YOU
BID AND ASK FOR A THIRD PARTY,
BUT I THINK THE WHOLE ELECTION
NEEDS TO BE ABOUT JOE BIDEN
EATING AND OWNING HIS BAD
POLICY.
>> PIECE SPEAKING OF HIS PER
POINT COACH RILEY, A LOT OF
PEOPLE THINK THAT THEY DID
BETTER THAN THEY EXPECT IN THE
SENATE IN 2022.
THAT THAT PORTENDS THE SAME
TRAIN, AND 2024.
WISE 20TH 24 DIFFERENT OBVIOUSLY
THIS PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, BUT
THE BASIC CAMPAIGN PROVIDED,
ESPECIALLY UP AGAINST STRONG
POLICIES AND THE OTHER SIDE, IN
THE TRUCK WHERE THERE TRAPS
AGENDA.
HOW CAN HE POSSIBLY SURVIVED
THAT?
>> I THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT
ONE IS THE POINT YOU JUST MADE
WHICH IS THE FACT THAT HE CANNOT
HIDE FROM THE SELECTION HE HAS
TO ENGAGE IN SOME WAY EVEN IF
IT'S JUST FROM HIS BASEMENT OVER
TV.
OR WHATEVER.
IT IS JUST TO BE FAR MORE ABOUT
JOE BIDEN.
JOE BIDEN IS UNPOPULAR, BUT
THERE ARE OTHER REASONS THAT I
THINK THEY DYNAMIC IS GONNA BE
VERY DIFFERENT.
WHEN AS YOU POINT OUT THE SENATE
MAP IS VERY DIFFERENT, AND IS
FAR MORE FAVORABLE TO
REPUBLICANS.
I THINK IF THAT SOMETHING LIKE
NINE DEMOCRATS HAVING TO DEFEND
SEATS, IN COMPETITIVE OR
REPUBLICAN STATES.
BUT THE LAST THING IS, THAT THE
REASON WHY THE REPUBLICANS DID
NOT DO AS WELL AS WE THOUGHT --
OR THE REASONS WHY DEMOCRATS --
SHOULD REPUBLICANS INTO HIS
MOTHER AS WE EXPECTED INTO IS
FOR SOME REASON THEY FAIL TO
CLOSE THE DEALS.
BUT THAT DOES NOT MEAN THAT
THERE ISN'T AN ENORMOUS
FRUSTRATION OUT THERE.
THERE IS NO MUCH FRUSTRATION OUT
THERE AND WE SEE IT EVERY DAY,
YOUR GOD AND THE REST OF THE
PUPPETRY OUTSIDE A D.C. IN
WASHINGTON THE FRUSTRATION IS
REAL.
AND IT IS PROBABLE.
AND FOR SOME REASON THAT DID NOT
COME OUT IN THIS ELECTION.
BUT IT IS GOING TO COME OUT.
THE NEXT TIME HE HAS TO COME